électrique a reçu les représentants
syndicaux pour leur annoncer un plan de
restructuration il prévoit la
suppression de plus d'un millier
d'emplois dans le territoire de belfort
entre les sites ji de belfort et de
bourogne le même groupe jean nous
promettait la création de 1000 emplois
beaucoup attendaient mieux de monsieur
macron qui a surtout su négocier
l'agenda de ce plan social qui arrivent
au lendemain des européennes
monsieur le ministre quels sont vos
objectifs en termes de réduction du
nombre d'emplois supprimés
êtes vous prêt à exiger le doublement de
la demande du parti
comment allez vous enfin associer les
élus locaux du territoire qui forment
une union sacrée pour assurer un avenir
à l'industrie régionale
c'est un coup dur pour les salariés de
ji bien entendu mais c'est un coup dur
qui résulte tout simplement de
l'effondrement des commandes de turbines
à gaz
vous connaissez parfaitement le dossier
il y avait 100 turbines à gaz qui était
commandé hadji belfort
en 2008 il y en a 29 aujourd'hui et les
perspectives pour les années à venir ne
sont pas bonnes et mon objectif
principal c'est de trouver de nouveaux
débouchés industriels pour les salariés
de ji à belfort il ya des débouchés dans
le secteur aéronautique
il ya des débouchés possibles dans le
secteur de l'hydrogène ou la ville de
belfort s'est beaucoup engagée et à
toutes les qualifications toutes les
technologies nécessaires
il y à des débouchés industriels
possible aussi dans le démantèlement des
centrales nucléaires et dans les grand
carénage sur tous ces sujets là que ce
soit l'aéronautique le nucléaire ou
l'hydrogène
les salariés ont les compétences et les
qualifications nécessaires pour
réinventer un avenir industriel sur le
site de belfort
je souhaite que la grande majorité de
cette somme de 50 millions d'euros de
pénalités payées par ji profite à la
réindustrialisation et à la réinvention
du site industriel de belfort je compte
sur votre soutien pour participer h 30
800 hectares en pleine forêt primaire
d'amazonie 10 tonnes d'explosifs et de
cyanure par jour est l'équivalent en
énergie de l'agglomération de cayenne
voici une présentation rapide du projet
de mine montant d'or en guyane la
montagne d'or n'est ni acceptable
aujourd'hui en l'état ni de même avec ou
sans réforme
madame la ministre nous attendons une
réponse claire et sans langue de bois
oui ou non le projet montagne d'or est
il définitivement enterré je le répète
de même que chacun des membres du
gouvernement qu'ils auraient à
s'exprimer sur cette question là le
projet ne se fera pas et nous allons
même encore plus loin
nous allons réformer en profondeur le
code minier de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent prendre en compte trois
conditions et pour délivrer un titre
minier
premièrement prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux deuxièmement prise
d'engagements sur les impacts sociaux et
économiques du projet troisièmement
assurances du consentement des
populations
et si d'aventuré un dossier était
déposée pour ce projet il serait
examinée à l'aune de nos standards
environnementaux et donc à l'aune de la
réforme est donc à l'aune monsieur
monsieur le sénateur je conçois que
concéder que nous fassions des choses en
matière environnementale que nous
prenions des décisions fortes vous
embête mais il ya une réalité il ya une
réalité c'est le projet de montagne d'or
ne se fera pas et que nous avons le
courage aussi
et nous avons le courage aussi de
réformer le code minier
voici le vrai visage du gouvernement je
sais pas si vous êtes champions de la
terre mais vous êtes champion du blabla
politique
[Musique]